[Music]
every president attempts to frame his
first national security strategy as a
break from his predecessors president
Trump is no different
well what's striking is how traditional
the goals of the new strategy are
protect the homeland promote American
prosperity deserve peace through
military strength and advance American
influence through diplomacy alliances
help for fragile States and by
advocating for American values and in
the strategy is larger goal of ensuring
a favorable balance of power in Asia
Europe and the Middle East a goal that
has been the cornerstone of American
grand strategy for decades and it's hard
to say that this strategy's broader
sweep is especially new ironically if
there is a break from the past it's with
candidate Trump's statements on foreign
policy statements that were often more
isolationist more protectionist and
typically harsher towards allies and
adversaries like Russia with those of us
who think that the traditional strategy
has served the u.s. well this is all
true do you think President Trump will
commit to his new strategy or will he
revert to policies he outlined in his
campaign let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI